in today's eight on your side are you  out of work or a gig worker who needs to  earn a little extra cash on the side  we've seen a time where more people need  ways to supplement their income  more businesses need help to stay afloat  and the fact that we can bring those  together  is really something that we're excited  to be able to do eric nalbone is vp of  marketing for drum an app that lets  people promote businesses from home to  earn commission  that's an example for you to refer  businesses products  services that you love to your friends  family network  and get rewarded for doing so now bone  says once you download the app it'll  show you the businesses and services in  your local area and you get a commission  when someone transacts  with that business brian